with a max speed of over 55 miles per
hour this tractor is the epitome of
awesome engineering we went to Sweden to
find out why wreaker created this
shocking machine rocket on our and Volvo
bayum terria from 1856 a big dent a
tractor race and a roll augusta majority
i also draw donuts based on our power
make some of bran for us photos of
Rangoon there are min father he tells
order so how did Ricker turn a farmyard
fossil into a dirt morning dragster
Ricard has massively upgraded his engine
he's gone from a capacity of 1.4 liters
to 2.3 liters that's a 60% increase
capacity relates directly to the volume
you have near cylinders the more volume
you know having your cylinders more fuel
you have exploding in your cylinders the
more fuel you have exploding the more
power you have now this engine it burns
more fuel also needs more oxygen to burn
it so the Greek art has also added a
turbocharger to the engine when a
turbocharger does it uses the exhaust
gas to run an air compressor that forces
compressed air into the engine the end
result of all these modifications is
that Ricard was able to bump his tractor
from 20 horsepower to 225 horsepower
more than a 10 times improvement Ricard
has also taken one ton of weight off of
this tractor which drastically reduces
the friction between his tires and the
ground
the cart has made this the perfect
vehicle for tearing up the farmyard yo
by going with the shortened Sabine
where's my Barney endless mom for it
another lily and keep them there little
super specially by shore mayor mayor
mayor sweaty bar just a goes on